[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000s uh as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey it's an exciting night tonight
because we are talking about ali reza
and we're doing that because this
farouza's on fire
you can you can clip that
uh gear is at home
um what am i talking about i'm talking
about his big win at the feed a grand
swiss of course ali reza took seoul
first place ahead of fabiana caruana and
gregory opran who tied for second i
believe they're the only ones that tied
for second but i might be wrong
um and qualified for the candidates
cycle next year so he will be in the
upcoming candidates tournament after we
get done with this uh you know current
world championship match coming up
uh so i want to look at ferrous games
tonight talk about why he is just
outclassing uh the competition now and
uh what what's going on in these games
some really fun ideas some really
impressive games by alireza so to start
with i want to go with uh
perhaps the most important round of the
tournament for alireza against david
howell so this was round 10 of 11 and
this is really what uh cemented alarez's
position uh in the lead
so we start with e4 e5 uh knight f3
knight c6 we get an italian with bishop
c4 and then black just plays bishop c5
uh alireza decides to castle we get
knight f6 and now d3
uh now you know there's obviously a ton
of moves here it's it's the italian uh
d6 and castles uh are kind of the most
sensible moves they are just the most
natural they help develop the pieces
uh they help get the king to safety
instead uh david howell plays this move
h6 now normally i wouldn't be so fond of
a move like h6 early in the opening
but there's a reason why black is able
to to play it here so i want to give a
nod to my comer here
and ask you guys what would happen if
you played h6 in this position what
would white want to play after h6 sorry
of course this is mike cummer's
recommendation to avoid the fried liver
attack
but it's not ideal because white can do
something pretty early on here
any ideas
uh not quite there's no like killer
tactics here um
queen h5 attacking a lot of things at
once but actually after 95 your bishop's
also attacked so those crazy tactics
just just aren't going to be good enough
but when your opponent wastes time early
on with a move kind of on the flank
very often it can be good to strike back
in the center and so the problem with h6
super early is that white's going to
play d4 in one move and then after
things start to open up
you're going to wish you had spent this
time developing with a move like knight
f6 rather than a move like h6 which is
not going to help you here when things
start to open up
so david howe only plays h6 after the
move d3 appears on the board and he's
able to get away with it because now
obviously d4 is no good and white kind
of already is uh you know not going to
gain a big advantage in time by playing
d2 to d4 in in one turn so h6 is just a
reasonable move it's good to control the
g5 square to stop these pieces from
jumping there and it gives the king an
eventual flight square for example as
well as allowing other ideas
uh in the position
uh ali reza continues with c3 just the
normal italian plan playing for d4 now
we get d6 rookie one castles uh h3 by
white uh this is a useful move again for
the exact same reasons
uh and now a5 by black
so uh a5 is i guess you could say a
newer idea compared to the old-fashioned
a6
and the idea is that we are preempting
any b4 ideas by white we're not allowing
white to gain a ton of space on the
queen side which is something that they
were thinking could cause problems for
black in the opening a few years back
now this idea of just pushing all these
pawns forward and getting a ton of space
so a5 aims to prevent that
uh knight b to d2 by faruja bishop e6
and bishop out to b5 and this is a move
i kind of want to talk about um farouja
in this tournament does this a lot where
he's not really trying to
kill his opponents in the opening uh
he's doing what magnus often times does
he says i'm going to keep some pieces on
the board we're going to play chess
forever and then you're going to make a
mistake before i do which shows you know
a lot of confidence for an 18 year old
at the top level and a lot of class as
well shows how much talent he really
does have
so bishop b5 avoids the trade and just
puts this bishop in position to
potentially drop back to c2 apply a
little bit of pressure to this knight
and now david howell plays this move
bishop a7 which is actually kind of
unusual here
um the idea is is not so complex he
wants to step out of d4 coming with
tempo just make it so that once white
plays d4 he's able to react immediately
but it's not the normal idea so there's
actually a really interesting maneuver
here that is normal for the position and
i'm curious if uh
anybody in the chat room or in the
audience is familiar with with black's
idea in this position
uh i think this position's been reached
something like 80 times in recent memory
and
in like 70 of them black goes for this
plan so it's far and away the most
common idea here
in master games of course
okay high tech physics says 97 to g6
this is a normal rerouting plan but it's
actually a little bit more unusual here
what black wants to do
knight b8 is kind of the wrong direction
we would rather go with this knight
remaneuver
in these e45 structures you know f4 and
f5 always going to be super critical
uh super critical squares
so that's why makes in seven knight on
g6
but that's not the idea
so i'll give you a hint black uses the
a7 square for a different piece here uh
a pretty unlikely piece actually
and yeah patrick daly in the chat has
the right idea queen b8 is super common
in this position and wow i even
undersold it um my database shows 116
games queen v8 played 95 times
so what's the point
well the point is that we have this
bishop on this nice diagonal white has
undefended the f2 pawn by playing rook
to e1 to support the center
and after white continues rerouting the
knight along normal plans uh we're just
actually going to go queen a7 make a
battery on this diagonal and force white
to play some uncomfortable moves either
rookie 2 to defend like this
when you can kind of tell this rook is
not in the ideal position
or just bishop e3 after which white is
able or black is able to comfortably
trade
and then continue on with these normal
maneuvers
and in in practice over the board uh
games that go this way oftentimes are
just drawn
but david hall goes for something else
he just drops this bishop back to a7
um now as white
this isn't really a cause for concern
here
you know bishop a7 isn't exactly the
most threatening move of all time and so
there's no reason to to deviate from the
normal plan with knight f1
now david hall does continue with knight
e7 re-routing we get knight to g3
and c6
okay bishop a4 by alireza this is the
normal way to reroute the bishop
and i'm curious if you guys can come up
with david howell's idea here
it wasn't one i was super familiar with
but i'm not exactly you know an italian
expert
i'm curious if you guys can come up with
what david howell was hoping for in this
position
so what would be the quote-unquote
normal thing to play for in the position
yeah um
and it doesn't need to be like uh the
next move per se but what is what is
david hal playing for what is he trying
to
achieve okay there's a few unusual ideas
in the chat someone wants to play queen
c8 and go for some sacrifices
um and then yeah uh her worst brought in
the chat says uh d5 is the normal idea
and that's correct d5 is the you know
the normal thing that they play for here
um but when they play for d5 i'm not
saying it makes sense in this particular
position but normally they actually drop
the bishop back to b6
and the reason is after we play all of
these moves
c6 bishop a4 we have this idea of just
dropping the bishop back to c7 now why
would we want to put the bishop on c7
well because the hurdle to playing d5
is that we need defenders of the e5 pawn
that's what's stopping black from
playing e5 and so it makes sense to drop
the bishop back to c7 defend this pawn
on e5 and then we can play for for d5 we
still couldn't do it immediately of
course because the pawn is still hanging
but for example knight g6 and black as
well on the way towards playing this d5
move
now in the games that i've seen where
black goes for this it oftentimes
doesn't actually work out that well
white is breaking in the center first
just because his pieces are are further
developed than blacks by by nature of
having the first move
so david is actually playing for
something entirely different in this
position he put this bishop on a7
obviously b8 is just a worse square than
c7 it interferes with our major pieces
they're no longer in connection
so what is david's idea why bishop a7y
this c6 move what's what's going on here
okay queen b6 is one idea but uh this
move actually is is always gonna have a
very easy response by by white um
i think white is gonna be quite happy to
play bishop e3
um the only thing you have to calculate
is is what's going on here
um and i'm not entirely sure what's
going on here but it looks rather scary
to do this and if we don't have this
move something like queen c2 followed by
bishop e3 is is gonna be good enough so
queen b6
it's not something so tactical
yeah rookie two as well as patrick
pointed out
and yeah the the chat members are are
getting it now uh the idea is to
actually steal
white's plan that i talked about so
remember when i talked about this move
a5 i said it's preempting white's
expansion on the queen's side grabbing a
lot of space
and so because uh white has spent so
much time uh just sort of fumbling
around with the knights not going for a
quick d4
black is actually the one taking over
all of the queen side space now
and i think this is a pretty nice idea
by by david howell you know not fighting
white uh so much in the center right
away but taking some extra space on the
queen side while white is preparing this
d4 break
bishop c2 is the best square for the
bishop for the same reason why bishop c7
was a normal idea
and now just a4 by david hell he just
really puts all of the pawns as far as
they can go taking all of this queen
side space and hoping for counter play
on that side of the board
you've probably heard when your opponent
attacks on the flank you should strike
in the center and so that's what furuja
does now
d4 very strong move uh he's put all of
his pieces on the optimal squares the
knights supporting the center the bishop
supporting the pawns from behind rook
and the queen already well placed
so nothing left to do but play the move
d4
and now again i have to give david hal a
lot of credit uh because he dealt with
the pressure on this in the center very
very well here
so what david comes up with is the move
knight g6 to start
which is just defending the e5 pawn it
was attacked twice
and now after bishop e3 just rook to e8
supporting the center from behind
we get bishop out to d3 by ferugia which
looks kind of like an unusual move uh
because you're interfering with the
queen's access to d4 but fruit is just
trying to make it a little bit more
difficult on black to be able to push c5
or even d5 by having some extra pressure
on b5
now bishop b6 by david howell is
the idea
opening up this line for the rook and
potentially eyeing some new diagonals
for the bishop
we get a3 by faruja stopping any a3
ideas or b4 ideas
now queen c7 by david howell rook to c1
uh very calm positional maneuvering
bishop a5
uh pinning this pawn to the rook so
alireza unpins now we get queen to b7
and again i want to ask you to find uh
ali reza's next idea in the position
because
i think a lot of people's understanding
of the italian uh when they're you know
first really getting into chess kind of
ends with uh you know
play d4 right that's your idea in the
opening you want to play d4 challenge
the center get a bigger center than your
opponent but
the question is always what comes next
what do you do after you get d4
so let's take a moment here for alyreza
and try and find the idea
okay some people in the chat saw the
game live um so they have the right move
but try and uh explain why you think
that that's the correct move why would
he play that
so what to do we've got our big center
we've improved our pieces to the maximum
so what comes next
exactly we want to open things up
um that's the advantage of having more
space whether it be on the center or the
queen side or the king's side when you
have more space your pieces are going to
be better placed to deal with the
opening of the position so as it sits
all of our pieces are very very well
placed but they don't really have much
to do while the position remains closed
so what alyreza needs to do he needs to
open it up so he has some targets in the
position
uh so how can we open things up to try
and uh induce weaknesses in black's
position and find some targets for white
okay so take on e5 is one of the options
so black would likely take back with the
e5 pawn and the question is did that
opening up of the position favor white
or uh or black
and unfortunately i don't think this is
the right way to go about things
you can play something like rook to d2
to try to get on this file but black is
actually pretty well equipped to handle
the opening of the d file right and
you know as far as what targets did we
did we actually um
unlock by playing dtx e5 i'm not so sure
we open the d file but we don't have
much to uh to focus on
so something better than de5 here
and the youtube chat again is is kind of
feeling the the heart of the position
just look at the white pieces they're
ready to attack they're ready to come
into play
you just need to to open the door
just need to open the door here
all right so i'd like to hear at least
one more idea before i just show the
position so
knight f5 okay knight f5 always a good
idea when you can get a knight on f5 in
this specific instance i think it might
actually lose tactically i think you
might be getting forked at the end of
the day
which what's going on here
is a different story but i think this
one is good for for black
um maybe
a little bit unclear still but something
like knight d5 here you've got some
weaknesses you do have the bishop pair
but very complicated stuff so you got to
be careful about knight f5
c4
c4 yeah there you go that's the move i
was fishing for so why is c4 better than
something like uh something like d takes
e5 well if black ignores it let's say
black plays like
rook c8 or something
what's a good follow-up now for uh
for whites
as patrick and spend fine gold would say
c4
is explosive
and yeah the chat's suggesting d5 which
i think is really strong here and the
idea is is pretty simple you know with
all of these things in tension
something is is going to open up and
black will have some pretty serious
problems
uh if you try to you sort of stubbornly
keep things closed uh eventually you
know i can either take on b5 i probably
don't want to take on c6 here
um
but uh and actually i think this might
be a better order just doing something
like this
grabbing all this space or potentially
not even playing uh d5 and then i am
better prepared than black for the
opening of of the c file
and white's just going to have a pretty
significant advantage here these pawns
down the center of the board kind of act
as a wedge you know the knights are
trapped on one side of the board
this bishop for example trapped on the
other side of the board and even the
major pieces are going to feel this a
little bit you know the queen of bishop
cut off from the king's side the knights
cut off from the queen side whereas
white is going to have a lot more space
to maneuver around and play on both
sides of the board that's just a
significant space advantage now for uh
for ali reza so instead david howell
goes for b takes c4 he says the queen
side is where i have more space so i am
going to open up the b file and find
counter play here
of course we're going to take back
and then david hall also comes up with
this move d5 and so far this has been a
very well played game d5 is actually
correct and
just by the way to show you uh how time
management is going on at these top
levels
uh in this position both players had 90
minutes left
um david howell
played this one pretty quickly ali reza
spends 15 minutes on bishop d3
david spends 10 minutes on bishop b6
another 10 minutes on a3
uh 20 minutes on queen c7 and before you
know it
by the time c4 and bc4 is played david
hall is down to 20 minutes from 90
minutes so really complex stuff here
there's a lot to calculate in these
positions
and that's why
you know i really want to focus on this
because c4 is the critical idea this is
how you
open up the game it's how you get your
pieces in and how you can try to press
for an advantage so
takes and d5 is david hal's idea
uh we're just gonna drop the bishop back
of course we're not interested in giving
up on our center
uh black is again just gonna be the one
getting the better side of things now
so we wanna keep our center pawn and
play bishop d3
um david now takes on d4 the pressure on
e5 was was sort of mounting and
uh you know just all sorts of ideas
coming into the position so take on d4
knight takes d4
and then the computer here to maintain
the balance suggests the rather inhuman
bishop c7
letting white take here letting white
take here letting white play knight five
well i guess
letting white take here and and do
something else
um but it turns out all the lines just
just seemingly work out for for black
kind of miraculously instead david plays
the more human move uh bishop back to d7
uh but i'm you know it's it's really
hard to play bishop c7 with 20 minutes
on the clock
uh and now uh ali reza does find a very
nice way to to press for the advantage
here so we did it we cracked things open
now our pieces are in good position and
we just need the accurate follow-through
to secure an advantage
so now that you've opened things up how
can you improve the pieces you couldn't
improve them while things were closed
but now you are able to
so because alireza has played so well i
think there's actually a number of ways
where white can uh secure some kind of
advantage here so
if you think a move looks good you're
probably right
probably right
the one thing you do have to keep track
of is obviously these pawns are still in
tension
but as long as you manage that pretty
well i think you'll be okay
any ideas
yeah so knight df5 is definitely the
move that you want to play now the
question is can you play um so why do
you want to play knight df5 well because
knights on f5 are just very very strong
pieces as hopefully you've heard before
it applies a lot of pressure to the
king's side introduces all sorts of
sacrificial ideas
and of course it influences the center
from f5 and importantly for us here it
makes a threat so it turns out knight
df5 is correct because you can play it
there's just no time to take on e4
because knight to d6 is hitting a queen
and a rook
and for example
tough to find a spot to put this queen
but let's say queen b8
um white is just winning here because
knight takes f6 comes with with check
um so knight df5 is is the right idea
now why don't we want to use the knight
from the g file uh well because we do
need to keep some track of this pawn and
so that on g3 is actually
um you know important where it sits for
for the moment so knight dfi very strong
move
um now we get bishop back to c7
guarding this square
and now ali reza decides it's finally
time to deal with with the tension here
so he plays e takes
on d5
uh and then this is the moment where
david howell's position goes from sort
of uncomfortable to pretty clearly uh
i i would go as far as to say losing
he absolutely had to play this move
knight takes on d5 but with only nine
minutes on the clock
he could not calculate all of the
complications so
why do we want to take with the knight
well it turns out that this knight on f6
is actually a little bit loose and it
gives white some tactical opportunities
that we'll see in a moment
and outside of that black is actually
also looking to plant knight onto f4 and
that's his way back into the game he's
trying to fight back
against the white pieces rather than
just try to hold everything together
instead he comes up with the more
natural move pawn takes on d5
getting this pawn off of
the
the eyes of this rook
but now there is just a very strong
improving move for for white you just
see the white pieces start to creep up
the board
until uh you know eventually everything
falls apart
so one more really good improving move
here for whites and then the tactics
will start to flow
as somebody famous once said you know
chess quotes are attributed to everybody
but tactics flow from superior positions
so this is ali reza building his
position
and then once his position is good
enough the tactics come
rook c2
so rook c2 it does make a threat but
um i think bishop e5 is actually a
desirable move for for black so rook c2
might be forcing black to play a good
move
so keep in mind the idea of this knight
being a target and the sacrificial ideas
we have over here we're not sacrificing
yet
but we're building up our position with
that on with that in mind
yeah that's exactly right so
uh i also i i like this move for a
number of reasons it's it's the best
move it introduces ideas of takes on f6
or takes on h6
and it also highlights how bad isolated
pawns can can be sometimes
um we think of isolated pawns being bad
because they are weak you know they
can't be defended by their friendly
pawns uh but there's a number of other
problems that sort of come along with
them one of those being since the pawn
is isolated the squares in front of the
pawn uh often fall to to the enemy's
control and that's because they're
natural outposts there's no enemy pawns
that can jump up to kick this bishop
away or any other piece away
and the pawn actually sort of plays for
white it provides shelter against enemy
major pieces like the rook or something
and when you look at these bishops you
start to realize you know how is white
you know how's black ever going to
contest these bishops
it's very very difficult
so bishop d4 is the type of positional
move you you dream about it just shows
how bad black's position is is quickly
becoming
um so as black david hall's in a very
tough spot how are you supposed to deal
with these threats to the night are you
supposed to you know ever get rid of
these pieces
uh something like bishop b6 is desirable
but just way too slow we can take on h6
we can take on f6
probably we take on h6 here but
without getting into it
and so david howell comes up with this
move bishop to e5 he's trying to contest
this bishop's control over these dark
squares and prevent the tactics
but alireza has a nice find in this
position
but actually he misses the absolute best
move so see if you can find now the the
tactical knockout
to secure uh secure a big advantage here
you've built up your position enough and
now
things will crumble
in the chat they say if alireza didn't
find it i doubt we will well you guys
have the advantage of
you know
being allowed to try more than one move
and the first two moves suggested in the
chat are the the the move played in the
game and and the best move uh kind of
amazingly
so
let's give the in-person audience some
time to think
see if you can come up with anything
so these aren't easy tactics by any
means but
it makes sense that they're in the
position
okay so you can um black's going to
recapture
probably with the knight
oh well i'm sorry
yeah if you capture with the knight
you're you're absolutely correct 96 is a
problem so rook takes would be forced
you're on the right track here
definitely on the right track
so how can you remove this defender
yes and this is uh pretty much the the
crux of the tactic for alireza now
unfortunately
in this position it's not quite working
because black has this nice move rook
takes e2 as an inner meso and after we
take black takes back what black is
going to be up a piece and we don't
quite have just enough compensation we
could even we could throw this in but
still the extra piece for black is is
enough here
um but
see if you can improve upon that idea
there's two improvements alireza played
one of the improvements
uh but he actually missed the even
better version
okay what order is that
at age six ticks
bishop takes and yeah that's actually
what alireza played in the game uh so
this one's pretty good um david howell
plays bishop takes g3 and we get into
some very complicated tactics here and
we'll look at those in a second but
there's actually something even better
you know see a good move look for a
better one
so i liked your idea of taking on e5 but
there's actually a way you can get rid
of this problem of this inner meso
does anybody want to try to be the hero
they're not your pieces so you don't
have to worry about giving them away
throw away all of ali rez's pieces if
you want to
all right any final guesses
okay so as patrick in the chat says
amongst some other people rook takes e5
is the killer killer move here
um if you play the natural knight takes
you run into this same tactic that you
guys spotted earlier
and uh white is just positionally
crushing here without the dark squared
bishop
for black the bishop on d4 is just a
monster
and there's no way back into this game
for for black
and if you take with the rook you run
into this exact same tactic that you
highlighted
but now
we fixed uh we fixed the problem and
this one is is just
uh it's devastating for for black this
one is just so
so bad i don't want to look at this
position anymore
so rook takes e5 was was the killer the
killer move knight takes h6 though also
very good white's going to have a
significant advantage here
so pawn takes what else bishop takes g6
is the idea so if you do the simple move
take back again we get this position
where white's going to have the absolute
killer bishop and an extra pawn
as well
so
david howe comes up with bishop takes on
g3
now at the risk of embarrassing myself
what happens on bishop takes d4 instead
uh
okay i'm not gonna ask you to actually
find all these complications but it i
believe we can simply capture on d4
our knight defends our rook and if you
capture my bishop and capture your
knight
not down a piece um i'm actually up upon
and your king is
pretty darn close to to just checkmated
here
so david hall comes up with some better
complications plays bishop takes g3
keeps things complex
now ali rez is going to take on e8 to
start
and then take on g3 or sorry not take on
g3
if you were to take on g3
what's going on here
i already don't remember it's just too
complex
just way too complex
i think
something like knight e4
i don't know all right i'm gonna cheat
on this one uh to save some time okay if
you take on g3 white is much better um
that makes sense queen f3 instead though
is is also accurate and maintains the
advantage
the idea is pretty simple
we want to checkmate the black king
and now david howe always resourceful
comes up with queen to c6
so what's this move about well this this
bishop still has some life left in it uh
it may not be long for this world but
currently it's here and so black is
making use of that in its defense of the
h2 square to play this this strange
looking move
and once again alireza always sharp is
is not one to miss the move here
uh if we were to play simply do
something like uh rook to d1 just saving
our rook bishop e5 is is going to hit us
and once again black is keeping the
extra piece this queen now defends the
knights
so something sharper
that's actually going to be the
incredible move bishop to c2
so what's the point of bishop c2 well
it's very very unusual
the idea is that
white needs to not have this tension
between the queen and the rook for a
turn because he's not able to capture
just yet but by playing bishop c2 he's
actually preparing to move the bishop
back out of the way and then capture the
queen once this mate threat is gone
really crazy tactic and
uh you know i'm gonna say i don't think
i've i've seen much like this tactic um
just in chess you know blocking the rook
so then you can unblock the rook a turn
later it's it's absolutely crazy now
again there are very complex lines but
to keep it simple we're going to stick
with what david halt shows which is
bishop back to b8 and now
we are simply just capturing this knight
on f6 again this doesn't work just yet
because of bishop h2
but the much more complex line happens
after bishop e5 trying to defend the
knight that's when we would go with
bishop h7
and
i don't even want to talk about
everything that's going on here
and basically you end up in this
position where white is picking up one
of these pawns
f6 for example uh takes on h6 and you
end up in this really really crazy end
game uh at first blush it looks like
black has more pieces and should be
doing okay
but it turns out
with the weak king and with these pieces
sort of scattered so randomly across the
board black's going to have a really
tough time coordinating the pieces and
white's going to have a simple plan of
slowly but surely pushing these pawns
down the board should be better for
whites although i definitely think this
is what david hall should have gone for
because in the game just gets this very
sad position
so again we don't need to talk about all
those complications just wanted to show
that this bishop h7 idea was in the
position
uh instead bishop all the way back to b8
and now ali reza just gains the piece
back on f6 take take
and now that the dust has settled white
is just up a pawn
i do want to highlight the technique
that the daily reza shows off in this
game
bishop back to c3
and here david howell makes sort of his
last big mistake of the game i would say
and this is where it goes from probably
a losing end game to definitely a losing
end game
as it currently sits he's down a pawn
but maybe he can try to hold on
having this pawn here on d5 is you know
it can be defended on that square
but david goes for a trick he tries this
move d4
and the point now is that if you think
you're going to get away with capturing
this pawn
you're going to run into some run into
some trouble
defending your bishop bishop f4 for
example
if i block
take take bishop f5
and david's back in back in the game
but of course alireza spots this and
plays bishop back to d2 and then we'll
see that the pawn on d4 is just a little
bit too far advanced black's not going
to be able to hold onto this pawn and
ali reza shows fantastic technique
calmly going after this pawn winning it
and then winning the game
so just to show you
both players improve their pieces
we see white um fix this pawn on h5
as always um this structure is usually
the best structure you can have with
three pawns on the king's side and the
end game what's the reason for that well
the weakness in the structure is the f2
pawn and the king is able to centralize
itself itself while maintaining its grip
on this f2 pawn
if you compare that to if white plays
king f1 here you have two weak pawns in
the position now and the king is not
defending g2 if it were to to go over to
e2
so just a good nuance there fixing the
pawns like this is usually advantageous
we get the king to the center
and after bishop to e6 bishop db5 is
important when i pressure this pawn
after bishop b3 we bring the king to d3
white's plan is very very simple now i
want to take this pawn and there's not
much that you can do about it
um king to g6 and a few more nuances
from ali reza bishop d7 is super nice
just keeping this king out of your face
gives you plenty of time to maneuver
your bishop quick offer of a trade
check and bishop c5 and now as expected
the d4 pawn falls
we continue on a little bit check king
c1 and then david hell actually resigns
here because ali reza is is picking up
believe it or not a third pawn on the
next turn no matter what you do
check
and you got crisscrossed no way to
defend h5 and resigns so very very
impressive game by ali reza a very dense
game as well um and ali rezo is just
sort of pumping these games out uh all
tournament uh super complicated
positions uh he seems to just easily
outplay his opponent find the right
tactic and then convert with with
stellar technique and that was pretty
much the story of the the entire grand
swiss um
so i am going to review everything that
we just talked about a little bit but
any questions for me on this game
anything that was confusing or didn't
didn't make as much sense
okay well let's go through the important
parts one more time
so to start with we have this opening um
david howell's interesting idea is to go
after all this queen side space
uh farouja doesn't flinch
uh introduces the tension into the
center after he introduces this tension
he improves he improves his pieces to
the maximum to prepare for the opening
of the position
once his pieces are on their ideal
squares he finds the right way to break
it open all his pieces are itching to
get into the game he can't improve them
further until he opens it up he does so
with c4
and then after d5 challenging in the
center we see him stay calm
and then improve with knight d to f5
uh fix a target here on d5 as well as
targets on the king's side
after his position is improved to the
maximum he finds the tactic with knight
takes h6 pointing out the weaknesses the
loose pieces
and then after some accurate calculation
navigates the complications gets to a
better end game and then converts
using just normal end game principles
and good solid uh
calculation
and that's the game that's how you beat
david howell easily
you know it's a bit of an oxymoron
beating david hall easily but that's how
ali reza did it
okay
with that we do only have like 13
minutes left but i am gonna attempt to
show you another full game uh we won't
go quite as deep on this one but i had
to give a shout out to my boy favi he's
had a couple rough tournaments uh but
he's back in style getting second place
in the grand swiss
and i believe he's the only person to
manage to to knock alireza down a peg
in their game so i wanted to take a look
at this one
show that perhaps there is still
one or two aspects of the game of chess
that alireza could learn from against
the absolute superstars fabi and magnus
for example and i think this game
highlights that very well
so in this game favi plays e4 and
gotta love my man manfuruja playing the
caro khan
we end up in this line which is very
common now at the top level this is sort
of what they've been testing the keracon
players in this h4 move
of course if you were to play e6 big
mistake your bishop is trapped
big mistake
so players with the black pieces have
been playing h5 these days
securing
some control over these light squares
and now white's idea is simple we just
go bishop d3 trade off these bishops
activate the queen and in the olden days
they would play the move e6 here
but white's point is that by playing h5
you have given up a lot of control over
the g5 square and i'm going to have a
very active annoying bishop sit on this
square
so
these days uh the players with the black
pieces have been playing queen a5 check
and the idea now is this is actually
preventing bishop g5 in a really weird
way
you would want to just play bishop d2
but if you do that then queen a6 and it
becomes very difficult to avoid this
trade of queens
and if black is able to trade the queens
black's not going to be much worse in
the opening
so
knight to d2 oftentimes is played
instead the idea being now if queen a6
the knight controls c4 and i can keep
the queens on the board keep some
tension in the position
so that's what's played here uh
knight to d2 and then okay not queen to
a6 of course because c4 is strong
instead it's time to play this move e6
and then fabi shocks everyone okay not
yet
now after 92 97 fabi shocks everyone
with uh with a killer idea here
uh so in this position black has one
super common break does anybody know
what what the break black plays for is
in positions like this
pawn break i'm talking about
so white has the big center we need to
challenge the big center how can we
challenge the center
so f6 is one idea and that's actually
what we see in the game but black would
actually probably prefer to attack um
not f6 immediately by the way but
eventually
black would prefer to attack this d4
pawn with a move like c5 sort of where
his pieces are angling he wants to
develop this b8 knight out behind this
c5 pawn and put a lot of pressure on d4
open up the c file for his rooks and
find counter play in
with this plan
and so what fabi does is actually really
annoying he plays this move b4 shocking
idea um and looking at the database it
looks like he might have stolen this
idea from maria muzichuk one of the top
female players
uh
she was actually the first to play this
idea and she did it in even more
shocking fashion she just plays b4 here
take my pawn with check see if i care
but fabi perhaps tries to improve on the
idea waits a little bit and plays b4
here now if you play queen takes b4
you're going to get hit with rook to b1
because you've developed this knight to
e7 your queen can't come back this way
and this is going to be some nasty
business now for uh for black with not
enough space the king gets stuck in the
center of the board definitely don't
want to be playing into lines like this
so instead ellie reza just drops back to
a6 but with b4 we now have a new way of
avoiding the trait aside from c4 now
white actually just brings the queen to
b3 the queen is nice and solid behind
the pawns and he's gonna you know push
all these guys at his leisure alireza
comes up with knight f5 get knight f3
knight d7
uh a4 by fabi just takes extra space no
reason to not play it queen to c4 is ali
reza's idea now
finally he can get this trade of queens
bishop d2 take on b3 take on b3
uh and now f6 and so the point i wanted
to highlight is by playing this move b4
uh we have just entirely shut down
black's plan of playing c5 there's just
there's no way to do it now b4 controls
the square so so well uh so much so
that ali reza does have to go for this
uh sort of backup plan of f6 attacking
that the head of the pawn chain rather
than the the base of the pawn chain
and with this
we see that the threat is is not
actually so severe we have
the e5 pawn defended enough times and
it's actually very difficult for black
to add any more attackers so white
simply castles we see after bishop b7
both sides just improve their position
gradually king f7 rookie one uh and then
ali reza goes for for a capture on e5 it
seems like the natural logical
continuation here
but unfortunately for alireza take on e5
is actually going to to give white a
better position and we'll get into why
in just a moment
but the point i wanted to highlight
where fabiano really outplays alireza
in this game is the opening now if i
flip on the engine
you're gonna see that the engine says
that this is 0.00
black is doing perfectly fine
but the issue is uh what the engine
recommends black uh to do
is nothing it wants to go rook ac8 it
wants to go a6 or b6 wants to go rook
hg8 for no reason let's play bishop d8
reroute it here come back here
it wants to shuffle the pieces around
and wait for for something to happen
uh and that is just not an easy way to
play as a human you know you want to do
something with with your position you
want to have active ideas you don't want
to be shuffling around waiting for your
opponent to try and find some way to
break through
uh and so because of that i think this
is where fabi is is excelling uh
compared to ali reza this type of
preparation that gets your opponent to a
position that's supposed to be fine you
know at the top level these guys they
can get their way into a position that
says 0.00 more often than not
but the question is how much time do
they spend
finding out if the position is actually
playable as a human you know it's one
matter to see if stockfish reads out the
zeros it's another matter to have the
position over the board be forced to
play it and see if you can actually come
up with the ideas you need to come up
with and that's the area of preparation
that i think fabi has excelled at uh and
that's the area where the younger
generation maybe has some catching up to
do not relying as much on that computer
eval and relying more on the practical
playability of things like this
because in the game after f takes e5 we
just get d takes e5 and now uh white is
actually coming in with this move knight
to f4 and we'll see some very very nasty
tactics uh
as well
so
why was f takes e5 bad well there was
actually a surprising but important
tactical resource in the position for
black so let's say we we pass if you
play knight f4 here
you're actually running into a nasty
idea by black which is knight takes on
d4 kind of a surprising idea
but it seems to be good the idea is
after takes we get takes on e5
and i'm going to be picking up the piece
and at the end of the day things are
going to get complicated
but black is going to be doing uh doing
fine in these positions i think bishop
f6 is correct
knight f5 and
looks kind of scary but the d puns are
strong here black is going to be doing
okay let's see if i'm lying yeah
computer reads reads zeros once again
with the move bishop to e5 so kind of a
scary line but it's a resource that
black was relying on to keep white's
pieces sort of a little bit more at bay
and again that's why i'm sort of saying
maybe stockfish can handle something
like this but you know balancing these
strange tactical resources and keeping
track of them to keep the white pieces
out not going to be easy at all for for
a human player so instead ally resin
actually wants to do something he takes
on e5 and then after rook c8 fabia's
going to bring in the knight to f4
and alireza again eager to do something
plays the move d4 you know taking away
some squares from from the white bishop
but it turns out that
it's just a bit too loose for for black
here he can't keep track of everything
and fob is able to provoke some
weaknesses
rook a to c1 is fabi's choice c5 again
black wants to break into the position
open things up he doesn't want to sit
around
but now knight to d5 comes in and
turns out that these are very difficult
moves for black to deal with if you were
to take
e6 check is a familiar tactic now
not to mention 9596 coming in later
so takes on b4 is played instead
now knight takes on e7 knight takes on
e7 and fabi actually misses a direct win
here with simply taking on on b4
after this move knight c6 for example to
defend bishop d6 now knight g5 and
knight takes e6 are sort of unstoppable
and white is just sort of crushing here
instead fabi gets a little bit impatient
plays knight g5 right away
and this allows black to get into this
end game where uh it looks uncomfortable
but it turns out
black is actually just holding on by a
thread here
so very scary stuff white has these
connected past pawns and is aiming to
push them up the board but black does
have counter play against the queen side
pawns using the d and the b pawn
to create enough threats to keep himself
in the game now unfortunately though
this is going to be a lot easier to play
with white than black just because
you're like 3 10 p away from winning the
game at at any moment
and so fabi does end up securing the
victory in this game um rupee one to
defend uh knight e4
takes takes
and at the end of the day uh i i don't
exactly remember which move that the
engine calls out as the losing move but
it's just impossible to handle all these
threats with no time on the clock as
well
knight's d4 is played here at this point
i think black is is already losing if
you play something like rookie 8
white is actually sacrificing all of the
pieces
and
see if you can come up with the winning
move here this one is is rather nice
highlighting just how powerful white's
pawns are
the rook might be able to stop two pawns
but maybe there's more pawns in the
position than than just the two
yeah g4 and then believe it or not white
is just in time here
just in time
oh yes and as alex who's about to teach
uh points out if you play h7 the rook is
able to stop these two pawns
but f7 takes away that square from black
and now uh the rest is history rook f6
is h7
um
and there's there's not much else the
check doesn't do enough
queening with check
and fabi goes on to to win this game so
uh if i would be so bold as to offer
advice for ali reza um i would say that
his mistake in this game was you know
not necessarily playing a bad opening
but he got a position that's difficult
to play as a human the engine might read
zeroes but i i would find this position
kind of impossible for for anybody
and that's why fabi was able to get him
here
okay with that
also yes alex points out that uh
you know i think it's related to the
position being difficult to play um
but uh
yeah alex points out that fabi really
pressured alirez on the clock here as as
well and just showed more composure
handling handling the nerves and
everything all of which i i agree with
alex is saying
he's played fabi he understands the kind
of pressure
yeah
okay well with that uh that's enough out
of me uh let's hear it from the man
himself alex will be coming in to teach
directly after this thank you all so
much for joining me on the road to 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you